I've been using the iPhone 15 Pro Max
for 2 months now and I'm now even more
convinced that this has been the single
best iPhone to upgrade to in years and
that's based on my own experience of
using the new features and changes in
the real world instead of just looking
at the specs on paper so in this video
I'm going to go through the features
that I've actually been using day toay
which should ultimately help you decide
if you should upgrade or wait another
year so let's get right into it first of
all I would not recommend this titanium
blue color because it gets fingerprints
all over it now it's not as bad as the
previous stainless steel model but it
definitely does and I already have this
little scratch on the paint which is
very noticeable so with that said I do
recommend the natural Titanium because
you're not going to be seeing those
scratches and there's a lot less
fingerprints the new rounded Edge design
is absolutely amazing it feels so nice
in your hands and it's a massive upgrade
in terms of hand feel compared to the
previous design because it no longer
digs into my palm anymore the new USBC
Port has been awesome especially now
that I can share my charging cable with
Android folks or basically any other
devices which is really cool and I do
have the new USBC charge key from Nomad
on my keychain which means I always have
a charging cable with me no matter what
I've already used USBC in the real world
to play games on my huge projector and
also to run my Peltier phone cooler so
it's nice to see it supports so many
different devices but other than those
two occasions I haven't really been
taking advantage of USBC that much but I
can see a lot of people making much
better use of it for working with files
editing videos or anything like that and
now that it's been over a year with the
dynamic Island I now believe that it was
an excellent choice moving forward into
the future because right now a lot of
different apps are starting to take
advantage of it like when you're going
on a flight and you always have your
info there it's extremely useful and for
navigation it's just been great and with
that said let's move on to something
that's been a bit of a hit or miss in
terms of my personal use which is the
action button yes it's cool and all and
I was very hyped for this when Apple
showed it off but I honestly haven't
really been using it that much but
before I explain what I mean I've got to
show you guys this the new Max safe
stash stand case from our sponsor ESR
it's basically a do-it-all stase making
it easy to watch scroll use Mac safe and
carry with asr's original and patented
stand design that's built into the
camera bump itself allowing full Max
saave support with a thinner flush back
for faster charging with, 1500 GS of
holding Force while giving your phone
military grade drop protection with the
air guard Corners they also have their
Cloud series which uses premium soft
silicon for a better feel and enhanced
grip with five layers of multi-level
protection and strong Max safe magnets
ESR has their armorite screen protector
with armorite triple protection which
pass their 110 lb pinpoint force test a
10,000 time scratch test and a 4T ball
drop test and it's even micro curved for
Total Protection and it comes with
individual HD lens protectors as well
and you can order them today by using
the link below to get 50% off for esrs
Black Friday sales event I initially set
the action button on the new 15 Pro Max
to open my camera app but I realized I
kept opening it the traditional way
instead so I ended up recently switching
it to open the Tesla app to preheat my
car now that it's freezing cold outside
and I know noticed that I've been
constantly using it so it's actually
quite useful in the real world but this
isn't a Make It or Break It feature so
don't count this into your buying
decisions because it's not that big of a
deal now the battery life has been
simply incredible after the first couple
of software updates it lasts noticeably
longer than my old 14 pro Max and it
just seems to be able to hold the
battery well even while using GPS and
other tasks that eat up the power
probably because the 5G modem is so much
more efficient this year and speaking of
5G it's been noticeably better than it
was before because we were camping at
our campsite all summer and I noticed a
huge Improvement in September when I got
the 15 Pro Max right away I noticed
better sell service even being able to
make calls and use Twitter reliably
without needing Wi-Fi my 14 pro Max
couldn't even make calls and the
internet wasn't as good now this past
weekend we also went out to to chill at
the same Campground with some guys from
the family in a rented sauna buus and my
service was just fine so it's a massive
real world Improvement to no longer have
issues anymore I also noticed that
whenever I leave my house it switches
from wifi to Cellular much more quickly
and without issues like I did last year
where there would be maybe a 20 to 30
second delay without having internet
which was extremely annoying and that
now seems to be completely gone now with
that said the new 15 Pro Max also has a
couple of really nice quality of life
improvements like for example it does
have thinner bezels which just look so
much better it just feels more immersive
and it's a really nice bonus to have on
top of that the new earpiece speaker is
now super thin barely barely noticeable
in the bezel and this is a big deal
because the previous V S14 Pro Max
earpiece speaker was quite big and
noticeable and you could actually see
specks of dust getting stuck in the
speaker Grill and it bugged the crap out
of me so that issue is now gone and I do
want to say that the speakers are louder
and they sound better overall and that's
also a really nice bonus because I
actually like to listen to the Bible app
and YouTube videos while in the shower
so it's loud enough to kind of overpower
the noise of the water moving on to
performance the new a17 Pro chip
actually turned out to be better than I
thought and it seems very efficient and
all of the overheating issues have now
gone away which I was really
disappointed about in the beginning but
it's now really really good I did do
some gaming testing and surprisingly I
experienced basically no display dimming
at all when I tested in this office
which was actually shocking because the
previous 14 pro Max would dim after only
5 to 10 minutes of gaml and now it's
basically gone even at full brightness
which is crazy and I know that might be
because of the new more efficient
display driver but whatever it is I'm
very very happy about it and now let's
get into the last point I got to talk
about which is the cameras this is
probably the best year for camera
upgrades in many years with changes on
multiple fronts that have greatly
improved both the camera quality and the
convenience by adding more options first
of all this phone now takes 24 megapixel
photos standard which looks so much more
sharp especially when zooming in and the
same 24 megapixel feature now comes to
portraits as well which is so important
to me because I take a lot of portrait
photos now last year we did get the 48
megapixel camera but that was only
available in regular main photo mode it
did not work in Port portraits so this
is a massive upgrade for me we've also
got smart HDR 5 which makes the photos
look a lot better A lot more natural and
it's less noticeable that it was taken
on a smartphone instead of a
professional camera it just looks a lot
better there's also the new portrait
Focus mode which allows you to adjust
the blur afterwards when you're editing
it which is a lifesaver because
sometimes it just doesn't hit the blur
right so you can move it around it's
just incredible we also have the
noticeable improvements in low light and
selfie image quality it turns out a lot
better less noise it's just a great
Improvement for low light and night mode
as well but most of all the new 5x
camera has been incredible fun and so
useful in my real world use case I've
already been using it a bunch of times
naturally for Zoom shots to get a closer
view of things with a very unique focal
length I've also also Ed it for video
recording of subjects further away like
when we went to Monster Jam and recorded
this awesome close-up footage and
surprisingly the stabilization is
incredibly good considering the fact I
was holding it handheld I had my kids
around me it just turned out so good the
unique focal length itself makes it seem
like it was recorded on a pro camera
drastically changing how it looks which
has made it easier for me to record
sponsored videos at home without all of
the video clips looking so similar now
that we have the new 5x Zoom with the
longer focal length overall I'm
extremely happy with this upgrade more
so than my previous 14 pro Max and that
actually says a lot so I would
personally recommend people to upgrade
now specifically to the 15 Pro Max model
for that 5x camera but do keep in mind
that next year the pro model iPhones are
going to be larger with 6.3 and 6.9 in
sizes which means that the smaller one
is going to be getting the 5x camera and
they both should be getting even bigger
batteries so keep this in mind if you're
thinking about waiting so with all that
said hopefully you enjoy this two-month
review and if you did go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next
[Music]
video